[Music]
Hi, I'm Chan Walquist. I'm an architect at
Palunteer. Today I've got you Matthew Bayer
who's a forward deployed engineer or FDE on
our compute engines team. Thanks for joining
me. Great. Thanks, Jack. Great to be here. So,
compute engines, what is that? Yeah, so we build
a lot of infrastructure that transforms data
across the platform within Foundry. So if you
think about anything you're doing um that involves
tabular data transformations, we're owning that.
So whether it's a normal Spark transform or a
transform in pipeline builder or lightweight
transforms which we're going to chat about
today, we're sort of that backing engine for all
of it. Yeah. And may maybe just so everyone can
understand the the framing like we talk about the
multimodal data plan which is really a huge set
of features we're deploying around accelerating
data processing to get to AI and autonomy faster.
So you know we have things like our data bricks
integration we have compute pushdown there's
virtual tables all these different pieces and
components today with the lightweight transforms
I think this is really about how do we accelerate
the data transformations on the small and medium
size how do we actually reduce cost increase speed
um really accelerating people's journey towards
the AI and autonomy pieces right exactly and so
we've had a few trends sort of moving us in in
this direction for a while so if you look back
in history um we and you know much of the data
data engineering community was intensely focused
on Spark. The reason being it was sort of the
most economic way to transform your data. So
you'd have distributed compute, a bunch of small
nodes working together to together, you know,
do a large transform u and underly all of your
data pipelines. But that really has changed over
the past couple years for a few developments. So
the first is single node compute is a lot more um
efficient now. So as as compute and memory costs
have come down um we've seen these form factors
that are ideal change where you know you want
to look at a single node rather than something
like distributed spark. On the flip side we have
the AI revolution where folks are doing much more
interesting things with their data than they were
previously with just a standard spark pipeline. So
what a lot of people are looking for is something
highly flexible and generic where they can run
whatever compute engine, whatever AI workflow
on really flexible data scales. um to encompass
all these new developments. And so what we've been
building with lightweight transforms is the answer
to that. It's for folks who don't want to have the
overhead of a large distributed compute cluster
with Spark. Folks who want to enable AI focused
development and pipeline deployment wrapped all
together in one experience. Yeah, I think that's
it's an important call and especially as I talk to
customers like there are very few customers that
are truly at web scale and most enterprises are
working on billions or tens of billions or maybe
hundreds of billions in a larger scale where it's
like small and mediumsiz data that now can fit
in these larger form factors. And so it's it's
really kind of the the two things coming together
and accelerating those different kind of customer
profiles while still having the capability to
go do Spark and other large scale distributed
computing. But now I can pick and choose the
the compute that's right for my problem. I think
that's a pretty cool framework to think through is
now it's very interoperable. I'm not stuck in one
place. Yeah, exactly. And and I think it's very
easy to remain Spark focus given the history. So
previously even with moderate data scales, you'd
need to use Spark. And now we're in this whole new
regime where you know much of the um pipelining
that folks do is in the small or medium scale. And
so it's not worth the spark overhead now that we
have these you know new compute engines. So folks
folks are looking a lot at these newer compute
runtimes like uh polars, pandas, data fusion which
you know stand on the shoulders of the giant
of spark but have really introduced a whole
new paradigm for compute. And the the framework
there is single node blazingly fast rust or native
library based uh query engines. And so these are,
you know, introducing these tremendous savings
and speedups as folks look to either write new
pipelines um in these compute engines or migrate
their existing legacy Spark pipelines uh to one
of these newer uh methods. Yeah, that's very
cool. Should we take a look at it? Yeah, let's do
it. So let's walk through an example lightweight
transform. We're going to take an existing
Spark transform, migrate it to lightweight,
and see if we can pull some resource savings out
of there. So here we have a notional data set just
for store sales and transactions. You see we have
things like a transaction ID and a transaction
time stamp and it's pretty substantial. So we
have almost a billion rows here and it's almost
14 GB compressed. So it's going to uncompress to
something even much larger than that. And what
we're interested in today is you know looking
through these transactions and see if seeing if
any of them appear to be fraudulent. And so we
have this existing Spark pipeline set up that
does just that. So we're going to load in all of
this trans uh these transactions and we're going
to look at various features that are indicators
if it may be fraudulent. So we're going to look
at you know how many transactions the customer has
been doing recently whether they have behavioral
anomalies. We're going to look at network risk
and some of the qualities of that transaction.
And then we're also going to look at geographies
to see if it's correlated with anything there. The
interesting thing here from a pipeline standpoint
is that we're processing this incrementally,
which means as a new batch comes into the data
set, we're only going to process that and not,
you know, look at the whole previous data set.
But from the data engineering perspective,
we still need to look at the entire history of the
transactions. Why? Well, we're going to take our
new transactions in this chunk and we're going
to use the entire transaction history as a bit
more data to see if these new transactions look
fraudulent compared to what we've seen in the
past. So you can see we do that with you know
a relatively simple syntax. We just have this
transforms object and we pull a spark data frame
out and then we're off. What we're going to look
at is see is to see if we can uh translate this
to a lightweight transform namely using polars.
So what is polars? It's again one of those uh
it's a it's a new entrance on the field which
is a a blazingly fast single node compute engine.
So it's really come uh come onto the show over the
past couple years and folks have been adopting it
quite quickly. Um but I think the important point
to call out here is not just polars. It could be
anything that someone's choosing, right? So like
we're choosing polars today, but really you can
bring any compute engine inside the platform and
author that and actually run. I think that's
it's pretty cool here as you go through just
to think about this could be any engine you're
familiar with or specific to a use case. Yeah,
exactly Chad. And so we wanted to set up a very
simple declarative API there where you can really
just pull these into any set of common dataf
frame objects that you care about. So you can
see we're pulling it into a Spark data frame, but
there's nothing stopping us from doing polers,
pandas, duct db, or you know any of the top
end query engines just natively out of the
box. Cool. So first we're going to check out
a branch on this repository and you know see
if we can make this work. So, we're just going
to call it lightweight. Looks like I've typed
and we're going to head into the continue
plugin. So, one thing I want to highlight
here is that we really focused our DevX
on familiar open- source technologies. So,
this is just VS Code using the open- source
continue plugin as an AI authoring assistant.
We want this to feel as familiar as possible
when you're authoring in the platform,
you know, so it's just like if it's
on your laptop. And so here we have
Claude 3.7 Sonnet. And we're just going
to ask it to translate to lightweight.
Yeah, I think it's pretty neat that we have uh
the can, you know, basically bring VS Code into
the platform so you have it in the secure enclave
of Palunteer, have everything integrated with it,
but still have these tools. That's pretty
neat. Exactly. And on that note about tools,
I just want to highlight that what's actually
going on under the hood is we're using an agent
inside the the transform that you're offering
um as a fully blown tool enabled assistant.
So what we're doing under the hood is we've
actually built an MCP server for your transform
where it can do things like discovering the
transforms you've written, editing files,
you know, inspecting the data that you've imported
um so that your your agent has the maximal context
that it can get to help you author that transform.
And so we see off it's found this transform and um
it's going to do its work. Um this is going to
take a second. So while it works, I just want to
chat through two previous runs of this build, one
in spark, one in lightweight to sort of highlight
those differences. So if we look here, here's the
lightweight execution. We see it takes 2 minutes.
And so you know what does that mean? We're going
to look at the previous Spark execution and see
how long it took and the resource usage. So let's
take a look at Spark. We see it's at 220, which is
roughly the same time. Um, but if we look at some
of our observability tooling, we're going to see
that it took a uh much larger amount of resources
to run. So, if we head into our Spark details,
we see this because our Spark pipeline ran with
16 executives, each with 16 GB of memory. Even
though our pipeline only took 2 minutes to run,
it's actually 21 full minutes of compute with
hundreds of gigabytes of memory allocated to
it. So, this works. It's reasonably fast. Um,
but we can eek out, you know, much larger savings
by moving to polers in a single node environment.
And so let's check out what we can see for the
lightweight transform. Well, it's going to look
similar. We have telemetry. And, you know, because
we aren't using Spark, we're going to supply more
generic container uh metrics and observability
for whatever you're running within this computer
runtime. So, we see it takes 2 minutes. And if we
hop on over the metric tabs, we we can look at uh
CPU and memory usage. So although we ran in a much
uh in a similar amount of time, we only used about
29 GB of memory throughout this transform, which
is, you know, almost 10 times smaller than what
that Spark uh pipeline was doing with executives.
For the CPUs, we can see we're hovering right
around eight CPUs, different from the 16 exeutors
with two cores per exeutor. Um so about a 4x
reduction in CPU cost there. So we can see just
by uh translating this small pipeline away from
Spark, we're incurring um savings and a bit of
a speed up. But that sort of begs the immediate
question of hey I have this transform um it's a
big lift to move off of Pispark, you know, is it
worth it to save these costs? And so I just want
to highlight here that um whereas that would have
been a hugely costly operation a couple of years
ago with LLM assistance, you know, it really just
works with, you know, with a wave of the hand.
So we can see I think our LLM is done translating
our pipeline. I'm going to click accept and it's
going to start applying its edits to the transform
that we have in front of us. So you see it's going
through it's importing polars there. And I'm just
going to let this run as it it makes it stiff. So
just highlighting a couple things. It is applying
the lightweight decorator which we could see.
We'll we'll let it run but we'll take a look.
Um really all it's doing here is applying a
decorator to your Python function that enables
lightweight mode. You can configure the amount of
resources, so memory and CPU you want on top of
it. Um and then all we need to do is is write this
logic in polars instead of Spark. So I think it's
pretty pretty neat though too is just to think
about from like a translation standpoint of you
know if you're the senior developer and you're
like hey I need to go this would be something
you might hand off to a junior developer to go
like handle this task. the fact that in the few
minutes we're talking, it's gone and done this,
figured it out and actually making these changes
like this is pretty powerful from man, I have
hundreds of pipelines and I want to get the
value of speed and cost reduction. Well, now with
the continue plug-in MCP server behind all these
different toolings, it's literally just a simple
question and go. Yeah, exactly. So, previously
we saw that data engineers who were authoring
pipelines would take a while to upskill on certain
libraries. So they'd be learning Pispark or Polar
syntax and they'd become the person who wrote
those pipelines. With continue and you know new AI
authoring tools, it sort of uh it moves everyone a
level up. And so what that means is you're really
thinking about data engineering concepts. So do
I want to filter here? Am I dealing with a big
join rather than being bogged down in the syntax
of the particular library that you're working
with? And so we can see here it looks like it's
done. As I mentioned previously, we've applied
that lightweight decorator uh with the resource
requests that we're looking for. And instead
of uh reading in a Spark data frame, we're just
pulling in Polar's data frames. And these come
in just as so. So if we scroll through, it looks
very similar to the previous pipeline just with
Polar's calls. And we can kick off a build there.
So a journey and the fact that you can
do all this in a branch, test it out,
uh, you know, having the foundry branching across
everything is super powerful for stuff like this
too and and do a diff even on the output to make
sure that the translation happened correctly.
Exactly Chad. So because of that um especially
with the branching concept on data sets uh what
this allows you to do is check out a branch in
the repository, try out a new change and then see
what the denser date is. As you were alluding to,
this is a super huge feature for things that look
like migrations since, you know, you aren't just
rolling production right over from Spark to Polar.
You can, you know, run two branches side by side
for as long as you'd like, assure that the data
is the same, uh, and then move move over at your
leisure. Um, yeah, I think you you you curs you
kind of went over quickly on the important point.
I don't think people in the data engineering world
normally think about. You are branching the data
as well uh, in Foundry. code, you can actually
do a diff on the actual data, not the schema, not
the just the pipeline and the code, but the actual
data. Yeah. And to that note, Chad, um especially
with these newer, maturing libraries, we see new
features, bug fixes, documentation being released,
you know, day by day, week by week. And so, in the
same way that you'd want to branch out for um you
know, a full Spark to lightweight translation,
we have the same concept for simple things like
version upgrades. So if you want to upgrade your
Polar version or whatever you're using, it's
super easy. We have a managed Python environment
within this repository. It would be as simple
as checking out a branch, upgrading polar there,
making sure everything looks okay, and then
merging straight into master that. Yeah, that's
pretty a pretty slick process here. Yeah. Awesome.
So yeah, I just wanted to chat a bit more about um
what it means to be a lightweight transform since,
you know, we're doing some very generic compute
here. We're running a pipeline with polars. Um,
but that's really only just scratching the surface
of what we've enabled here in lightweight. So
folks are doing things that are a whole lot more
interesting than simple tabular transformations.
And so we also, you know, wanted to encode in
the flexibility into this product to do things
that reflect more modern pipeline usage. So we
have full uh full-blown media integration where
you can download images and unstructured data,
transform them right alongside your tabular data,
and then output it to wherever you'd like. So if
you think about I think some data science teams
would probably love love that type of feature,
right? Yeah. Exactly. So where previously you'd
need all these different pipelines, you know, with
the whole web of thing flowing into one, but in
one place you can download images, say documents,
run OCR with, you know, whatever tooling or LLM
you'd like to use, output that into, you know,
maybe some agent that you have written in a
function um that can transform it in the way
you'd like and then really just output tabular
data. So this is you know encompassing polers
pandas or push down into data bricks or snowflake
should you like but really opens just a whole new
world of opportunities to do whatever you'd like
in a python runtime and then integrate it fully
with the foundry data set ecosystem. Yeah. And
I think what you're describing I I talk about is
like I need to make more data computable which
like the power of this is now I unlock so much
more context and knowledge across my business
because I can compute across different forms
and types. The multimodal component that's
why we call it the multimodal data plane.
uh right and so that is so powerful but it's
also super important because that context is
generally very important for really the end goal
of all of this is to get to enterprise autonomy
um you know AI agents automation uh these
which means I need to compute these things
that were stuck in PDFs and emails and phone
calls and videos y um and so the this tooling
unlocks everyone to move at the speed that the
different tooling is because I have I can compute
in the right way for the type of data and it
doesn't just have to be uh homogeneous. I can have
heterogeneous comput environments too. I think
that's the other thing here is like it doesn't
just have to be polars or duct DB. It can be spark
polars duct DB in different parts of the pipeline
even. Right. And that's I think super powerful.
Yeah. Exactly. And so um there's a whole spectrum
of places in Foundry where you can have you know
unopinionated to very opinionated compute. So if
you think about something like compute modules,
you know, that's all on one end of you bring
everything you'd like to run and it's literally
a Docker container running within the platform.
We've applied just enough guard rails here so that
you have an easy declarative API to get access to
data of whatever form or compute of whatever form
within a Python environment, but then we pass the
baton to you. So you're coming here with a Python
environment, but you can really do whatever you'd
like. And so lightweight transforms are one of the
key places where we've seen compute pushed down
to other providers u like data bricks or snowflake
or working with things like virtual tables because
you can just specify whatever inputs you'd like
into the lightweight transform here. So you see
we just have a normal foundry data set here but
these could be you know external connections to
another s3 bucket or a snowflake table or anything
like that and you can work with all of these
different sources side by side in one place. And
so, you know, the question you may ask then is,
well, why in Foundry? And the reason there is for
free, you get all of these full-fledged data set
uh features out of the box. You're going to get
security primitives. You're going to get the
branching that you were talking about previously,
Chad. Um, you're going to get lineage so you can
see where all of your data was coming from and
where it's going. And so, these are all these,
you know, incredibly useful data engineering tools
that you wouldn't get just running Python on on
your laptop or somewhere else. And the nice thing
there is we can just infer that and give it to you
for free just based off of what your inputs are
and what your outputs are. Yeah. And I think in
the enterprise space, you know, if you're working
in enterprise space amongst a team of people,
you need to be in this in this environment where
people can collaborate and work together. I
think the developer experience you're talking
about is is powerful of like I we have a wide
range of capabilities from if I want to be highly
opinionated or not opinionated and and giving you
the ability to kind of choose where you are but
work in an environment that has that security. I
mean especially even when we talk about vibe
coding like how you know now you're already
starting to see some of the stories gone wrong
of that of you know having the security you know
by default having the lineage and the branching
across everything. Yeah. Um that really is what
makes the difference in the developer experience
and the friction to really at the end of the day
get it to production. Exactly. Yeah. And
and you know LMS have been quite magical
in terms of authoring tooling and translation
tooling, but they do have the dark underside
where things do go wrong. So LMS have deleted
production databases. They've done all sorts of
things that go ary when folks aren't using them
in the right environment with the right context.
And so a place where you want to look at uh AI
assisted pipeline authoring is something that
looks like transforms. So you're going to have
security prim primitives where LMS aren't able
to access data that they aren't given explicit
permission to. Um you're going to have a standard
git style change process where they aren't just
coming away and um editing pipelines with nobody
knowing. They're going to you know going to raise
a PR and have it be reviewed and merged into a
repository just like how a human author would
do it. And so really in order to get all these
benefits of an LLM in a place like writing data
pipelines, you need all these features. They're
not optional. They're actually critical to make
sure that your data is staying safe and correct
when you're bringing LLMs into the equation. Yeah.
And I think really what you're getting at in in my
mind is is this is system level thinking. I'm not
a bag of tools I'm stitching together. You know,
when I was a prior customer, stitching all the
tools together was great until you you had to own
it and then update everything, connect it, secure
it, and different security primitives, different
scaling mechanisms. The system thinking here from
a developer experience means I can just move at
the speed that I'm thinking because all the tools
are integrated and work together. And I think that
level of speed to be able to go execute is what
people see. They're like, how does Palanteer
move so quickly? Yeah. Well, it's all these little
things that we make work together in the system.
Um, and that system level thinking is really where
I see us accelerating uh, every developer. Yeah,
exactly. And, and one thing to your point about
speed is that one of the biggest lags we've seen
are the folks who have the legacy pipeline or, you
know, the person who wrote it isn't there anymore
and no one remembers the details. It's and it's
incredibly difficult to, you know, either migrate
off those pipelines or upgrade them to bring them
up to date. Um that whole paradigm has changed
here as well as you think about you know managing
systems instead of managing individual pipelines.
Um with you know AI tooling migrations upgrades
are becoming much easier and with sort of this
transformed architecture where you're able to uh
preview data before you you know you commit it to
production. It's the perfect ecosystem where you
can experiment with upgrades, experiment to see,
you know, maybe that um Polar's version change,
introduce, you know, some different behavior that
you want to roll back where you discover these
things before shipping it to prod um it's huge.
And so when you have this sort of uh environment
where you can play around safely and experiment um
and verify the outputs of everything that you're
doing um it is also a huge accelerant to shipping
these things out to production and keeping them up
to date which is going to accelerate folks who are
working in your repo in the future. Yeah, that's
awesome. The other p piece I kind of want to hit
on that you talked about was the LMS and you on
the same back plane. So an LM can, you know, work
on a branch and it can put a PR for you to review.
Like those same primitives that you as a developer
are there for the LM to work with as well. Yeah.
So you know, we've seen a lot in the open source
mainly this year with coding agents really coming
into play for local development. And so one common
feedback or iteration loop we see with LMS with
local development is they'll do something like
making a change and then running the compiler. And
so if they've done something wrong, they're going
to see a compiler error. And in many cases,
the LM is going to be smart enough to go in,
fix the error that it made, and verify that that
was fixed. And that works great for code, but
we want to have the exact same sort of iteration
loop here with data, too. Since, you know, often
a transform or a pipeline will work correctly,
you know, output data, but maybe it's not what
you wanted. And so, in the same way that a human
is going to do this, we want to enable our LMS,
and we do to write part of a pipeline and then
preview the results. So you can imagine an LM,
you know, looking at the schema or the row count
or statistics of a data set that it's actively
building and iterating on. Um, and that allows
these LMS to go much further on their own in an
agentic capacity than they would from just, you
know, one shot writing a pipeline and hoping it
works. And so the nice thing there is, you know,
it really is the exact same way a human is going
to do it. They're going to be enabled by tools
within a closed off secure environment to build
these pipelines and iteratively roll them out to
prod. And so as these um LLM get better and better
over time, we expect that they'll just be more and
more adept at using the human level tools already
available within the repository uh for their own
good and so humans can be, you know, further and
further hands-off, accelerated, and again working
at the systems level. Yeah, I think this all goes
under the ethos of the AIFD is how do we delete
uh FD minutes uh from these tasks and having an
LM as your sidekick to be able to go do this. This
is this is pretty cool. Yeah, exactly. And so it
really extends through the whole, you know, life
cycle of a pipeline. So if you imagine the non
AI FD world of of the past, you know, you'd write
a pipeline and maybe it would be right, but then
you have to go into pipeline optimization where
you're digging deep into say Spark logs. You have
to learn what all of that means. You're tuning
the number of executives and resources available
to your pipeline. Um and it could be quite labor
intensive even for um an existing correct pipeline
if just the data grows or something like that. And
so uh we you know we want to enable the next step
here which is um automating that a bit more. And
so one of the key places there with lightweight is
making sure we're using modern resource efficient
libraries that an LM knows how to work with. So
you can imagine in the future something like
visiting an existing pipeline that maybe has
run out of memory memory. you've gotten an oo
error. Um, and having an LM just go in, you know,
bump the resource request or something like that.
Or maybe, you know, getting linting saying, hey,
this operation you're doing is a bit inefficient
for whatever transform you're trying to do. Um,
and just really accelerating those the human
instincts and insights into pipeline authoring
with this agent that of course knows, you
know, every dock of every compute engine,
has seen millions of pipelines that maybe, you
know, no human has ever been able to read uh in
terms of that scale. uh and then just bringing all
that context to a domain expert who may be writing
a single pipeline in a single environment. So
I'm super excited to see uh where this ecosystem
evolves to in the future. Yeah, very cool. I
just want to talk through, you know, what the
output of this pipeline is. So we can see we have
a very similar set of transactions with their ids
and dates, but we've gone through and have made
an inference about the fraud risk of a number of
them. So you see we have this new um column here
called fraud risk level and fortunately these all
look low which is good to see. Um but really it's
just been as quick as that. Uh we've fully updated
a billion row data set with one call to an LM and
I think one commit. So as we're looking at this
output data set we see it's actually grown since
we've added more columns to it. It's now almost
23 GB compressed. And so this sort of begets
the question of what is too big for a single
node transform and when do you need something like
spark and one thing that I've been super excited
by to see out in the open is a bunch of these new
libraries develop what they're calling streaming
mode. So some of the leaders there are dupd or
polars and basically what that allows transforms
to do is operate on data sets that are drastically
larger than your memory. And the way they do that
is by not loading the whole data set in at the
same time. So you can just work on it chunk by
chunk. Now not all transforms can be streamed
because sometimes you do need the whole data
set in memory. But if you think about something
simple like counting the number of rows or getting
you know a simple aggregation like an average over
a column, you don't need to load in gigabytes or
hundreds of gigabytes or terabytes even um all at
the same time. And so that allows you to work with
very small resource efficient single node setups
that are just scanning through your data sets over
a period of time. And so what that allows us to
do is lean much more heavily in the lightweight
setup than just falling back to Spark because a
data set is large. So um given the new parameters
that we're working with in the single node mode,
I would say almost every transform that I see in
my day-to-day could be run with lightweight with
a single node. Now you may need a lot of memory in
the node. You might want to add a lot of compute
to get it to run within a set period of time. Um,
but it really is the exception that you need a
large distributed Spark setup these days that
you're talking, you know, hundreds of terabytes
or incredibly expensive transforms on data where
you do need to hold it all in memory. And so that
is just a key benefit of these new libraries that,
you know, unlike Spark are not Java based. They're
super efficient with memory management on the
system. Um, and they're going to allow you just ek
out a little more performance for a given set of
cores and memory than you would in, you know, in
the Spark land. Um and so and not just performance
cost. It's a big cost reduction. Exactly. And
so we've even seen folks um leveraging streaming
style compute for all sorts of creative ways. So
you can think about maybe uh ingress. So one thing
that you can do out of a transform is connect to
an external system. And so folks may want to just
read straight from some system and immediately
start transforming it in Python without any of
the extra steps. So if you think about something
like a streamed library in DuctTDB, you could,
you know, read from an external S3 bucket, write
some SQL against it, write some polars against it,
and then just be streaming it in from your
source and streaming it straight back out
right into a Foundry data set. And that would
be, you know, your your transform right there.
So we're super excited to see where that goes
and as new engines open up this feature. Um,
it's it's just incredibly cool to see what you
can do with a very small compute profile. Yeah,
and I think that's the the big transformation is,
you know, if you look step back and look at like
what is the goal, it's, you know, everyone's like,
I need a data lake. I need all of my data in this
one huge thing with distributed compute. Yeah. Um,
you know, actually the goal is how do I how do I
get this data to be used and driving decisions and
actions and and honestly make it available for AI
workflows or humans or or collaborating.
But it's that is really the end goal,
not to put my data in one place that it's in this
big distributed thing. And I think I'm seeing more
and more of that in in the customers I talk to is
getting the idea here is now I can do things like
this at a low cost threshold that gives me access
to data I never could process before and now I've
made more data computables. So that comes back
to my same theme here is I'm making more data
computable across my enterprise to drive better
context for those higher order workflows. Really
that's the end goal. Exactly. And so when you have
these like lighter form factors with an overall,
you know, smaller footprint and shorter run times,
it's just going to bring you that extra step and
keeping your data up to date, keeping it correct,
keeping your pipelines modern um to really drive
those those decisions there. I appreciate you
taking the time out of your busy schedule and
building all this cool stuff to come talk about
it. Yeah, it's been great. Thank you very much.